brandon saw his 10-game hitting streak
come to an end yesterday as he didn't
start but he ended up getting a couple
of his bats
deep in the right center that baby is
gone home run for brandon
and just like that the rays are out in
front
lao will not let up
and the rays take an early lead this is
getting to be borderline ridiculous
i mean brandon lau is just laying waste
to pitching the split it doesn't do much
that's a bad combo to brandon and he
deposited it so the race up one to
nothing and with a man on with one down
for g-man
choi
and he crosses him up and hits it fair
down the left field line
this will be a long long run for goriel
to go get the ball diaz is getting the
wave
and is out at the play
what a throw by goriel
well he's got a strong arm and lourdes
picks up his first outfield assist of
the season he had nine last year
and that was a
long throw first of all it was a long
run to get to it and you knew that the
rays were going to send the base runner
diaz as he starts out at first base troy
gets jammed and rolls it down left field
line look how far guriel has to run and
he's got time to take a peek at the base
runner and then he throws it all the way
on the fly to danny jansen who puts the
tag on diaz what a terrific throw from
the left fielder no question about it
and now ryan yarbrough who struck out
the side in the first we'll face the
oscar hernandez to begin the second
on the roster right now is hernandez
launches one and i mean launches one to
left center field what a shot and this
game is tied and wow just like that and
that had tremendous sound boy hitters
love to hear the crisp crack of the bat
when they square one up he smoked that
thing nothing like it and here's
guerrero
now guerrero lines up on a deep left and
this one is gone guerrero goes back to
back with hernandez and the blue jays
take the lead
that thing was smoked as well fourth
home run of the season for vladi the
second time the blue jays have gone back
to back this season boy a couple of hard
hit homers guriel's got kind of a couple
of choppy swings of the cutter that's
okay that's what you have to do against
this guy
and this ball is crushed to left field
one hop up against the fence drury is
going to score biggio will stop at third
throw to second is not in time it's an
rbi double for goriel and it is three to
one boy three really hard hit balls here
in the second inning by hernandez
guerrero and goriel bridget finds
himself in a no for ten rut after
striking on the first
a little broken about on the right side
one hopper throw to first they don't get
him
as a second run comes home
on just an insane slide at the plate by
gurio to avoid the tag ray's obviously
want to go take a look at that but watch
this he's going
here's the tag attempt boom boom boom
he hopped right over it
hopped right over it and got his hand on
that plate did he get it oh boy that is
so so close a big call because this is
either inning over
or ending continues another run on the
board
we may have a call dwayne
they have overturned that second
play at the plate the rays
prevail after a lengthy challenge and so
they'll take that run off the board it
turns out to be a four-run inning for
toronto six in a row now set down to by
shoemaker as he starts yandy diaz and
there's a shot deep into left center
field that baby is well gone
another blast
number two for yandi diaz and the reigns
get one of those runs back most home
runs are pitched that was a pitched home
run and yandi didn't miss oh it sure was
moving into the bottom of the sixth
inning and they'll be looking at a new
pitcher ryan burrucky takes over so
martinez off the bench to pinch hit and
a ground ball through the left side
toward the corner that will score lau
diaz hitting third they're going to try
to score him the throw
loose in the infield
and this game is tied
pinch hit for martinez he winds up at
second this time the throw from left
and the reigns have tied it at four so
brand new ball game the rays have tied
it and threatening to take the lead as
charlie montoya goes to rafael dolis
rutter's lead from every base another
3-2 pitch and he got him what a job by
rafael dolis rapio dolis walks the
tightrope but he averts the damage he
leaves the go-ahead run on it we are
knotted up at four as we head into the
night well he faces vladimir guerrero jr
into right field cutting toward the line
renfro he made the catch renfro grabbed
it and then had to leap that low wall
his momentum kept him going william
thomas i mean that you could hear the
race dugout up here
i don't know what was more impressive
the catch or the aftermath of kevin
biggio leading things off against aaron
luke here with the top of the tent for
the blue jays
slices it down the left field line it's
a fair ball drury is around third and he
will come in to score biggio on his way
to second and in there with a double as
the blue jays take the lead a big
three-hit night for cabin and he drives
home the go-ahead run lourdes guriel
he's had an rbi base hit earlier in the
game
a little inside out swing and a fly ball
to right center field
runner tags here comes the throw and
bizio will score standing up to make it
six to four
well sometimes the game looks so easy
doesn't it ray's gonna need two to keep
this one going and three to win it down
six four and they will face jordan
romano yandi diaz has been on base all
four times
wow begins at second and there's a base
hit into right here comes loudest score
and that's going to make it a one-run
game it's 6-5
and now here's hunter renfrow
the pitch
and a bouncer back to the mound romano
has it and the blue jays will win the
opening game of the series at tropicana
field and extend their winning streak to
six
[Music]